fermi allora sto per giocare a uno dei
giochi che è andato di più nella storia
dell'ultimo anno perché nell'ultimo anno
c'è stato un gioco che è un po ha
pareggiato lo slider man come krypi
pasta non saprei neanche spiegarlo
perché un sacco di gente ragazzi ne
parla da un sacco di tempo e stiamo
parlando di siren ed testa sirena regola
dietro io non so niente
giuro su dio non se non ho visto niente
ma so che è conosciutissimo torcia e si
vola welcome to south point che ti posso
park ma mi dove la rt dice dove il
prossimo obiettivo ok quindi ti fa
andare ed è sempre molto adesso zumba
sulle robe mi piace che ultimamente
ragazzi non so se avete notato ma gli
horror anno stila la grafica tipo in vhs
la cassetta sono tutti sta grafica gli
horror tutti quanti volevo precisare di
nuovo di nuovo una caratteristica molto
figlia di sto gioco premi il tasto r per
vedere l'obiettivo perché effettivamente
sono nella foresta non lo vedo premo il
tasto r
e sparito l'obiettivo già una foresta
infinita con alberi invalicabili vuoi
perché non si riesce a passare in mezzo
starò ok non ho idea di dove sia quel
[ __ ] potuta torre non lo so ci devo
andare al naso e un posto orribile non
si capisce niente però credo di essere
sopra la parte
o forse no giovanni livello delle luci
rosse potrebbe essere la ai ragazzi lo
vedo le luci rosse strane forse laggiù e
forse faccio in tempo qua sto camminando
non sono anche correndo cioè se non
arrivo così veramente un amico più lo
sento che laggiù ragazzi era giù lo
sentono iniziamo a prosecco la torre
watchtower the watchtower e non vedo
neanche lo più eccolo lì quello schifoso
di un laido pezzo di fango va bene
allora siamo arrivati in cima alla torre
raga c'è una radio oppure cosa mi dai
per iphone prestiti on the keyboard ok
cosa ci posso fare se non mi ridà radio
non funzionava bene però o lo sniper
perfetto ho sempre mi dice di rimanere
qua quindi non so se dovesse parlare e
vedere prepararti ma se mai lui che non
capisco se lui o no
no quella è una torre di segnalazione so
se lui pensa fosse siren ed non è
comunque tutto questo mi fa vedere che
devo ancora stare alla torre all
obiettivo 6 tutto sfacciato oppure è
successo qualcosa vediamo in giro a
vedere se scusa adesso cecchino in
qualche modo siren ed orari elmi kill
you higher a sniper rifle c'è un
cecchino pronto per sparati in bocca zio
se in qualche modo riescono o aiuto l'ho
mandato via ce l'ha fatta
sono forte succhia miei adesso l'ho
visto arrivare perché al trattore
l'amica visto sta arrivando di nuovo no
sono sopra la torre non puoi farmi
niente faccia di sirena
testa di culo vieni se ha il coraggio 26
ti vedo
vieni qua basta 2 che sei sport mi vedi
qua sony culo di fango è diventato call
of duty sto gioco attenzione non è
neanche il cag atto gli sport un
proiettile in faccia non ha pagato
a destare culo soave aiuto qualcosa
quando lo fa niente o so che avuto la
collina oddio sembrava un film quando
tipo ti segue le mico e capire alla
collina e ti salvi fantastico è successo
non sono morto per un miracolo va bene
giovanni vieni giù che non ti piglio sta
scendendo sentono il cammino equa eccolo
eccolo a pino come andiamo aiuto a dai
l'ho colpito due volte
ap anni quanto muoiono più proietti mi
sa che piano io no no no comunque un
gioco fatto bene a livello di
programmazione per un bijoux non ho più
proiettili che faccio chiamo
l'assistenza pronto non ho più
proiettili
vabbè rimango sopra la torre altro punto
che ve devo dire ho fatto tutto in giro
sparato tutto quello che avevo magari le
sono finiti i proiettili mi dice
qualcosa di nuovo può essere un cazzo
provare ragazzi non ci è rimasto niente
altro che fare una cosa è l'unica cosa
che ci è rimasta a parte guardare
steiner che si muove adesso arriva
quello ammazzo ti possa s'inscrive mi
butto dal palazzo e loro lo figlio con
la macerata a giovanni madonna euro
vivibile a pino vieni qua un attimo
resulting rock ei sono più alto di testa
di minchia di qua avvicinati che ti
faccio una di quelle che ti chiamo una
ginocchiata della iniqua
cagasotto di qua c'è casa è che
aiuto travaglio non funziona ma cala con
i vostri amici lo se ne va ma com'è
possibile è andato del parco sono vivo
tutto bene signori ho provato a far
fuori dal range modo di non lo so è
gestibile situazione ma ho provato
comunque a farvi valere effettivamente
secondo me sign ed potrebbe essere
battuto
se mi passate il file in alta qualità di
baby shark perché se io li metto veti
shark e dalle sirene secondo me muore da
solo raramente sarà quello il finale del
gioco
tutto questo sono in una foresta non
posso anche più metterla torcia non mi
fa più cambiare una che l'arma quindi la
mia fine si avvicini
nel mentre ragazzi spero che questo
video sia stato di vostro gradimento o
se qui ci rivediamo in un prossimo video
di cerca il mio amico che ha le sirene
al posto della testa sicuramente
possibilità sarà vuvuzela ed che sarebbe
il 2 david primis funziona che se in uno
stadio e devi scappare lì credo non lo
so ragazzi nel frattempo io spero di non
beccarmi farti cediamo ad un prossimo
video anche perché sono arrivata al
limite della foresta andati in pace bei
ragazzi
[Musica]